okay let's go into land of speculation
uh what about intelligent life uh
us humans consider ourselves intelligent
surprisingly
uh or unsurprisingly
do you think about from your perspective
of looking at planets from a
gas composition perspective uh
and in general of how we might see
intelligent life
and your intuition about whether that
life is even out
there i think the life is out there
somewhere the huge numbers of stars and
planets
i like to think that life had a chance
to evolve to be intelligent
i'm not convinced the life is anywhere
near here only because
if it's hard for intelligent life to
evolve then it will be far away by
definition
well the sad thing is uh maybe from the
artificial intelligence perspective is
it makes me sad there might be
intelligent life out there that were
just not
like the pathways of evolution
can go in all these different directions
where we might not be able to
communicate with it
or even know that or even detect its
intelligence or even comprehend its
intelligence
and convinced cats are more intelligent
than humans that
that we're just not able to comprehend
the
the measures the the proper measures of
their intelligence
my dog is so funny he's the golden
doodle his name's leo
we joke that he's either a really dumb
dog and so he's not here to defend
himself but he's either really dumb
or he's a super genius just pretending
to be dumb yeah
and it's possible he's he's a
multi-dimensional projection
of alien life here monitoring
uh one of the you know one of the top
scientists in the world trying to find
aliens just to make sure
just just to make sure that humans don't
get out of hand that's funny oh
i'm definitely going to go in and ask
him ask him about that
ask him about that he's on to something
yeah what might we look for in terms of
signs of intelligent life
from your toolkit do you think there are
things
that we should we might be able to use
or maybe in the next couple of decades
discover
that would be different than life that's
like bacteria
that's primitive life i still love seti
search for extraterrestrial intelligence
i like to hope that if there is a
civilization out there they're trying to
send us a message
i think like think about it i don't know
what are your thoughts like if you think
about our earth
there's no structure we've built that
intelligent civilizations could see from
far away
there's literally nothing not even the
great wall of china and so to think like
why would this other civilization
build a giant structure that we could
see
yeah so with seti the idea is that we're
both trying to hear signals and send
signals right or
we haven't sent when they call that medi
messaging and there's a big kind of
fear over medi because do you want to
tell them you're here
it's kind of this like let's wait till
they call us yeah
so uh dating game you have to
like how how many days do i wait before
i call kind of thing
yes it is and so but the funny thing is
if no one's sending us a message if
everybody's only listening
how do you make progress that's right
and
i mean but there's also there's the
voyager spacecraft so we
have these little pixels of uh robots
flying out
all over the place some of them like the
voyager reach out really far
and they have some stuff stuff on them
okay i just
we do we have the voyager but they're
not really going anywhere in particular
and they're moving
very very slowly on a cosmic scale yeah
and let me say they're far as
it's kind of silly because yeah it's all
relative in astronomy it's all relative
yeah yeah i just i so from the
if you look at earth from an alien
perspective
from visually and from gas composition
i wonder if it's possible to determine
the degree of
maybe um productive energy use
i wonder if it's possible to tell like
how busy these earthlings are
well let's zoom out again and think
about oxygen
so when cyanobacteria arose like
billions of years ago and figured out
how to harness the energy of the sun for
photosynthesis
they re-engineered the entire atmosphere
of the atmosphere has oxygen now like
that is a huge scale you know they
almost poisoned everything else
by making this what was apparently very
poisonous to everything that was alive
but imagine so are we doing anything at
that scale like are we changing anything
at like 20
of the earth with a giant structure or
20 of this or 20
of that like we aren't actually yeah
yeah that's
that's uh that's humbling to think that
we're not actually having that much of
an impact i know
but we are because in a way we're
destroying our entire planet but it's
humbling to think that from far away
people probably can't even tell but from
the perspective of the planet
when we say we're destroying you know
global warming all that kind of stuff
what we really mean is we're destroying
it for
a bunch of different species including
humans
but like i think the earth will be okay
oh the earth will be the earth will
remain
whatever whatever happened to us the
earth will still be here and it'll still
be difficult to detect any difference
like it's sad to think that
if humans destroy ourselves except
potentially when nuclear war
it'd be hard to tell that anything even
happened yeah it will be hard to tell
from far away that anything happened
you